Collaborate and listen.
Ice is back with a
brand new invention.
Something grabs
ahold of me tightly.
Flow like a harpoon
daily and nightly.
Will it ever stop?
Yo, I don't know.
Turn off the lights
and I'll glow.
To the extreme I rock
a mic like a vandal.
Light up a stage and wax
a chump like a candle.
All right, stop.
Can someone unlock the car?
Go rush to the
speaker that booms.
I'm killing your brain
like a poisonous mushroom.
Deadly.
When I play a dope melody,
anything less than the best
is a felony.
Love it or leave it.
You better gangway.
Pretty impressive, huh?
How good is mom?
Problem,
yo, I'll solve it.
Check out the hook
while my DJ revolves it.
Ice, ice baby.